hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
this is a fun problem that appeared on a
math exam in scotland
130 years ago in 1888.
a person walks from rugby to london in
four days and back in five days
each day he walks one mile less than on
the preceding day
what is the distance between the two
places i thank the national library of
scotland for digitizing these old tests
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
we'll get started with a little bit of a
diagram
we have rugby and then we're making a
one-way trip to london
let's suppose in the first day the
person walks a distance of w
miles the next day the person walks one
mile less which will be w minus one
then w minus two
and finally the person reaches london
after walking w minus three miles
so the total distance from rugby to
london over these four days
will be the sum of these distances which
is 4w minus 6.
we now consider the trip back from
london to rugby
this will be a five day trip
in the first day the person walks one
mile less which will be w minus four
then we have w minus five w minus six w
minus seven and finally on the fifth day
it's w minus eight
so the total distance on the return trip
will be the sum of these distances which
is 5w minus 30.
so where do we go from here
well notice the total distance from
rugby to london is the same as the total
distance from london back to rugby
so we must have
4w minus 6 is equal to 5w minus 30.
we can solve this to get that w is equal
to 24.
finally we need to solve for the
distance between the two places so we
substitute back in
and we get the distance of 4 times 24
minus 6 which is equal to 90 miles and
that's the answer
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over 100 million
views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can math
the world a better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos and email me
a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support